みなさんに
。。。。。。。。
報告しなければいけないことがあります
あ、
動画のタイトル見たら分かるか
実は僕
昨日から・・・
学校に通ってます
さあここで問題！（DEDEN!）　僕の逝ってる学校とは！何の学校でしょーか？
♪
終了！
え～じつは、僕ですね～
昨日から。あの～～～
ドローンの！！学校
に通っております
まあドローンスクールっていうですけど
みんなドローンて分かります？
あの、この、くてぅぅぅぅぅぅｗｗｗって飛んで、最近
祭りとかでついらｋ
ドローン一応家に一応あるんですけども
使い方わかんない。なんか一応使えるし
外で使っても良いらしいんですけどぉ
・・・・・・
コワァァァィジャナイスカァ！
怖いんスヨ！何か墜落
とかしたら本当に怖いしぃ、
なんか変なとこで飛ばしてなんか犯罪
になってつかまったりしても嫌なんでぇｗ
てか炎上しちゃ
合法的になんか動画
の撮影とかにあーゆー空撮っていうか
空からの絵がとりたいなぁ
て思たときにぃ
資格ありゃいいんじゃね？と思って
ちょっとドローンをとヴぁす資格をただいまとりに
いっております。いやーもう逝かなきゃいけないんだけどｗｗ
居山路ドローンほんとすごいっすよ
まぢで感動します
資格けっこうちゃんとしたやつなんで３日
間か４日間ぐらいかかるてきなことをきいてるんで
もうちょっと通わな
きゃいけないんですけどぉ
ちょっと早くみなさんに
俺の†ドローン操作技術†を見せられればうれしいとおもっています。
では、逝ってきます！
0214mex
ﾌﾞｩｩｩｩｩﾝwwwwwwwwwwwwwww
すげぇ（小声）
あ一回ちょっと待てて
ドローン持ってくる
teacher:同じ回転していったら　はじめ:はい
そうそうそうそう
こっち側難しいですね
ﾊｯﾊｯwwww
tea:上手くこう・・・操縦して 恥:はい
ﾌﾞｩｩｩｩｩｩｩﾝwwwwwwwwww
はい、じゃあ機体の電源を切って
着陸上手だね
難しいなぁ
上に上がると
T:テンパル？ 恥:てんぱりますｗ
まあ練習するしかないなぁ
も↑や↓も↑や↓も↑や↓も↑や↓も↑や↓も↑や↓も↑や↓も↑や↓
howdy!ここでドローンを飛行させるのが許可が必要だったり禁止だったりする場所を紹介しよう！
空港の周辺
人口集中地域の上空
150m以上の高さの空域
以下の3つの空域のように、航空機の航行の安全に影響を及ぼすおそれのある空域や、落下した場合に地上の人などに危害を及ぼすおそれが高い空域において、無人航空機を飛行させる場合には、あらかじめ、国土交通大臣の許可を受ける必要があります。
国土交通省HPより
も↓や↑も↓や↑